there's a guy in harvard
uh named richard rangham and there's a
lot of people that believe this he wrote
this book that um
basically there's a lot of people
studying is what happened how did we get
from apes to humans like what was the
magic thing right a lot of people
attribute it to fire and ability to cook
meat
there's a lot of different theories
so
he actually um
his theory
how do i describe this is basically that
that the beta males one
that the the
the
apes that were able to cooperate
so you you the way you develop
cooperation is that there's a big bad
leader that
the the alpha male
that you can only
knock off their throne if you cooperate
and so we build big tribes that just
excel the cooperation by practicing the
overthrowing the leader and so and
anytime an alpha male would rise up they
would get we would we would uh develop
our skill further and further of
cooperation
and so we're all just beta males
uh the descendants of beta males that's
his kind of theory that cooperation is
fundamental and it's so distinct to the
the rest of the
neighboring animal kingdom
so fascinating i i wonder what you think
about this tension of violence and
cooperation and how important is this
cooperation to the core of yeah
if you you can look at it in the uh
in a given training room um
jiu-jitsu and mixed martial arts is solo
sports a solo athlete steps into the
cage or steps onto the mat but all of
your preparation is done in a
cooperative training environment with
many peers and
as much as it's an individual sport
all of your preparation is done as part
of a group
um
there's a sense in which
that's
an interesting metaphor for humanity
itself everything we do in life we do
alone but we grow up in this given
community and and what have you
um
with regards the the whole
alpha male beta male thing um
humans are
it's true this fellow is correct we you
know
most
primates do have very strongly defined
alpha males who
rule the roost and determine the entire
direction of the um
uh of
the community they they build around
themselves
um
humans on the other hand
don't have
an alpha male in that strict biological
sense of someone who's responsible for
the next generation
dominates all the
female population etc
physically dominates but we do on the
other hand have our own version of alpha
males as far as we have political and
sociological leaders who have a
disproportionate impact on the direction
of a community
so was a cooperation allowed us to
to have a greater scale of hierarchy
with the alpha male on top or the alpha
creature on top yeah yeah
that's a fascinating theory
okay in nature we're we're very weak as
a species so we needed to cooperate
cooperate in order to
to evolve that i think
made us uh the the top of the food chain
if you look at um
humanity in in nature
really the two things that seem to
more than anything else determine
whether or not a given human community
will be
successful in a predatory world are
numbers and technology
okay the more your numbers increase and
then the higher the technology of the
weapons and support systems you have
around you the more successful you'll be
in a predatory world
um
so it's not clear that just
killing off the idea of an alpha male
was
the the single biggest thing um
the rise of technology uh and the growth
of community after the imposition of
language these are other things that
would have been
very very important factors and and
humanities rise george you made an
interesting point if you look at humans
just the raw material of humans we're
we're [ __ ] pathetic
in a predatory animal kingdom we're just
the absolute bottom of the food chain
um we don't have a single
effective
weapon other than better than average
endurance that's about it
um
but you put us in a community
who can talk to each other with language
and give us the time
to come up with technological advances
such as metals
and suddenly a human
will go from
no combat effectiveness in the animal
kingdom to a a human armed with a simple
metal tip spear can kill
damn near any animal in the uh
in the animal kingdom when working as a
group
i'll beat your silver back you know how
oh i'll fight him in a deep water pool
because he cannot swim so i don't have
to touch him you'll throw him and i
can't get him into the pool you know why
because someone told me because i live
in a community someone told me that
information so i know he passed it on to
me yeah
he taught you
well you have to convince them to you
have to somehow convince them to join
you in the pool which is very different
yeah exactly